[Musique]
bonjour et merci de nous retrouver dans
le 7-8 loisirs toutes vos idées sorties
dans le département on commence tout de
suite avec le sommaire de ce numéro
jusqu'au 6 juillet montigny le
bretonneux organise ses journées
découvertes adultes et enfants peuvent
assister gratuitement à tous les cours
organisés dans les écoles de théâtre ou
le conservatoire de musique et des arts
de la ville josé cache un maire adjoint
à la culture reviendra sur les
différentes activités proposées tout le
week-end les jardins d'île de france
prennent des allures de fête pour
l'événement rendez vous aux jardins de
nombreuses animations sont proposées
nous irons visiter le domaine de madame
elisabeth à versailles un joyau de
verdure encore méconnu du grand public
dimanche 4 juin les fermes des yvelines
ouvrent leurs portes pour une journée de
festivités la 17e fête des fermes
organisé dans la vallée de chevreuse
le point avec mélanie peau qu'elle sur
le programme mais tout d'abord la
création à l'honneur pendant un mois à
versailles le mois molière a débuté pour
une 22e édition musique théâtre danse
plus de 350 représentations sont prévues
classique contemporain il y en a pour
tous les goûts mais aussi pour tous les
portefeuilles plus de la moitié des
spectacles sont en entrée libre
le maire de versailles s'est exprimé à
ce sujet au micro de mélanie poker
écoutez le il ya bien sûr beaucoup des
spectacles de professionnels et ce qui
est à noter c'est que
un grand nombre de ces spectacles sont
gratuits ça je tiens ça parce que je
pense que contrainte financière ne doit
pas être un obstacle à chaque année ces
nouveautés vous avez des créations qui
sont spécialement fait pour le mois
molière 2017 comme par exemple
actuellement au sénat répétition là à
côté de nous d'une pièce amphitryon de
molière qui ne put y est rarement jouées
et amphitryon qui sera jouée justement
tout le week end à la grande écurie
l'ensemble du programme du programme est
à retrouver sur le site internet
embarquez pour un voyage autour du monde
avec le festival escales d'ailleurs à
plaisir il revient dans le parc du
château le 10 juin pour une nouvelle
édition est toujours une programmation
variée des jeux des défilés des
animations mais aussi des concerts le
soir c'est même le groupe d'électro jazz
français electro deluxe qui achèvera les
festivités un événement qui souhaite
mettre à l'honneur la diversité
culturelle on écoute joséphine coleman
ce berger la mère de plaisir on est
ravis d'attendre les plus de dix mille
personnes qui viennent chaque année nous
rejoindre dans le cadre de ce festival
des arts du monde puisque c'est comme ça
que au départ il est né est aujourd'hui
bien sûr l'appellation escale d'ailleurs
chapote un petit peu toutes ses
activités
le but premier la génèse je dirais de ce
festival a été de mettre en place je
dirais une résonance par rapport à la
richesse ethnique que nous avions sur la
ville de plaisir plus d'une quarantaine
d'ethnies
[Musique]
montigny le bretonneux organise jusqu'au
6 juillet ces journées découvertes le
public peut assister à tous les cours
organisé par le conservatoire de musique
et des arts l'école de théâtre et la
maison de la réussite
de quoi vous donner quelques idées pour
vous inscrire l'an prochain et c'est
josé cache un maire adjoint délégué à la
culture qui va nous dévoiler les
différentes activités proposées dont
joseph la charge ou la ville organise de
nombreux cours notamment dans le domaine
artistique et j'aimerais tout d'abord
qu'on parle un peu du conservatoire
on peut s'inscrire à des cours de
musique ça va du piano à des cours de
chorales et même de harper lorsque vous
nous en dire un petit peu plus alors
déjà dans un premier temps tu si vous le
permettez on va parler du pôle musique
et théâtre
ce cas le conservatoire c'est une chose
mais on est quand même dans l'optique
d'un pôle culturel en 2020 avec cette
mutualisation des équipements que sont
le conservatoire de musique l'école de
théâtre et et
deux associations de danse enfin ça
c'était une parenthèse battant sur le
conservatoire de musique
on a un conservatoire de musique
aujourd'hui son nom il y le bretonneux
qui rassemble très précisément 560
élèves parce qu'on n'est pas un petit
chiffre non plus on a trente professeurs
et on a 21 disciplines d'enseigner au
sein de ce conservatoire des disciplines
qui tourne
prioritairement autour de pratiques à la
fois collectives mais aussi
individuelles et tout ça autour de la
création de projets diverses et variées
à savoir des symphonique mais aussi des
chorales
des spectacles des concerts dynamique
autour de ça qui est absolument
extraordinaire sur montigny il ya
vraiment de tout ça s'adresse vraiment à
tout le monde puisque il ya même des
cours d'éveil pour les 4 et 5 ans donc
même les plus petits peuvent venir
s'inscrire
exactement et d'ailleurs alors je sais
pas si vous aviez l'intention de
l'aborder mais en tout cas on a une
journée portes ouvertes qui est prévu
pour ça le 24 juin
enfin deux dates très précisément sur le
conservatoire de musique
on a le 24 juin ou na ou là on est
autour d'ateliers instrumentaux
effectivement on touche des enfants qui
vont de 6 à 10 ans où le public qui se
rendra
à cette journée portes ouvertes donnera
l'occasion aux enfants de toucher en
quelque sorte à quatre ou cinq
instruments à vents et cordes de telle
sorte à pouvoir être sensibilisés déjà
la pratique d'un instrument
et puis on a un autre rendez-vous qui
concerne justement les éveille les
éveils ou là on n'aura plus une
présentation qui se fera sous forme de
cours collectifs maintenant le
fonctionnement d éveil au niveau du
conservatoire de musique
oui ça commence très jeune c'est de la
petite section de maternelle jusqu'à la
grande section de maternelle et ça
consiste la première année à travailler
surtout autour de la pratique vocale et
puis la deuxième année une deuxième
année qui elle est fragmentée en deux
temps le premier temps
le premier temps où les enfants pourront
eux à leur tour touchés différents
instruments de musique
et puis un deuxième temps où on aura une
pratique d'un instrument qui commencera
à naître chez eux et on va parler
donc on a parlé musique et vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure justement le pôle
théâtre donc à l'école municipale de
théâtre également là encore de nombreux
coureurs sont proposées pour tous les
agents ne peut pas tout cela est évoqué
mais je dois faire juste un petit focus
sur un court en particulier c'est
l'atelier de commedia dell'arte oui
c'est exact alors c'est un atelier très
spécifiques
le reste des cours qui sont enseignées
sur l'école de théâtre sont des cours un
peu généralistes autour du théâtre mais
entend en tout cas celui là ça ses
spécificités
un atelier qui est encadré par un
professeur qui est kazimierz que rob ski
qui est quelqu'un d'assez connu quand
même sur la ville adressées à des élèves
qui ont qui sont déjà assez confirmé en
matière de en matière de théâtre et puis
étant peuvent trouver leur compte dans
d'autres cours et celui ci vraiment pour
ceux qui ont déjà un tube d'habitude
voilà tu vois un peu plus l'habitude
parce que c'est ainsi une pratique
théâtrale qui commande qui demande quand
même une certaine forme de rigueur une
expérience assez forte et qui tourne
autour de toute la tradition toute la
tradition de la commedia dell'arte de
fabrication de masques etc etc
oui on va terminer cet entretien
rapidement une annonce le 12 juin
montigny le bretonneux lance sa nouvelle
saison culturelle alors rapidement qu
est ce qui nous attend l'an prochain aux
côtés des choses extraordinaires je
pourrai pas tout balayé en une minute
mais bon qui est des choses très
diversifiés humour théâtre etc
quelques exemples tes ennemis qui sera
parmi nous après avoir reçu un certain
nombre de molière mais on ouvre la
saison avec anne roumanoff on la ferme
avec alex lutz
on va avoir entre temps françois xavier
demaison patrick timsit
grand nombre de grands noms du spectacle
chantal ladesou qui revient nous voir
berléand aussi qui revient de voir enfin
j'en passe et des meilleurs mais ça fera
l'objet très prochainement d'exactement
sept autres émissions tout à fait donc
en tout cas une programmation à ne pas
manquer on suivra tout ça de très près
merci beaucoup josé cachot merci à
vendre place aux on le rappelle les
journées découverte jusqu'au 6 juillet
encore un mois pour découvrir l'offre
culturelle de montigny le bretonneux
merci beaucoup josé klécha et ses
week-ends profiter des espaces verts
avec les rendez vous aux jardins
en ile de france dans les yvelines
plusieurs domaines ouvrent leurs portes
c'est le cas avec le domaine de grignon
à thiviers en vagues réunion mais aussi
à versailles avec le domaine de marie
antoinette et celui de madame elisabeth
et c'est ce dernier que nous vous
faisons découvrir dans ce reportage de
nombreuses animations seront proposées
regardez
un écrin de verdure discret comme un
joyau à l'abri des regards le domaine de
madame elisabeth 8 hectares de jardins
romantiques au coeur de la cité royale
pour sa première participation au rendez
vous aux jardins et paroles de jardinier
il se dévoile aux visiteurs à des
animations culinaires des animations de
décoration florale mais également des
producteurs et des pépiniéristes des
yvelines avec bien entendu une touche un
petit peu sucré avec des produits un
producteur de miel et de l'éco pâturages
donc beaucoup d'animations pour petits
et grands
j'ai toujours une pensée assez douces
pour madame elisabeth qui était un
personnage qui vivaient dans ce dans ce
beau domaine qui comme vous le savez
était la soeur cadette de luis m elle
était très amoureuse de la nature donc
ça sera notre marraine pour ces deux
jours là un domaine sans pesticides
depuis plus de dix ans les jardiniers
s'engage dans le respect de la nature
ils feront découvrir leur travail avec
un détour par l'orangerie et son
laboratoire d'expériences en plein air
un vivier de plantes aromatiques
tout est comestible dans quasiment
jardin que ce qui est appréciable c'est
qu'on peut manger donc du jardin à
l'assiette quasiment donc on prend une
plante on la goûte on la savoure on a
l'odeur y aura une association qui fera
découvrir
des tisanes comment on peut faire avec
son jardin des tisanes personnel donc
avec une culture avec une cueillette sur
place et après une préparation en salle
se soigner grâce à la sauge ou à la
mélisse un privilège royal désormais
accessible à tous l'orangerie ouvrira
également sa première exposition sur des
jardins connecter à découvrir dès les 3
et 4 juin
[Musique]
le beau temps devrait être là ce week
end et mélanie pour notre rendez-vous
juniors vous avez justement choisi de
nous emmener faire une activité
extérieure est ce que ce dimanche qu'a
laissé la 17e fête des fermes dans la
vallée de chevreuse une journée complète
pour aller à la rencontre des
producteurs éleveurs et agriculteurs du
parc naturel une journée à vivre en
famille ou grand nombre d'activités
concernent des enfants et cette année
trois fermes participent à l'événement
dont la ferme de grandmaison à chevreuse
ça fait même disant que martin et
frédéric blin leurs portes de leur
élevage ce sont des éleveurs de bovins
des blondes d'aquitaine plus précisément
ils ont près de 500 bovins avec environ
160 naissances par an il pèse il possède
aussi 60 brebis et 110 agneaux et 50
poule de pontault pour les oeufs alors
pour cette édition il propose plusieurs
animations écoutez pas photo le montage
les chevaux
on a prévu une animation tout d'abord
avec un maréchal ferrant qui va nous
expliquer le faire devant nous avec la
forge un fer à cheval
il y aura donc un spectacle à cheval
donc au total le western avec un typique
une insulte dans la prairie derrière moi
donc plusieurs chevaux où on pouvoir
donc par ce spectacle et les enfants
vont être installés de le tout autour de
2,7 prévus qui est donc clôturé en tout
pour assurer la sécurité des enfants et
il y aura aussi une balade à poney
accompagner une des balades en tracteur
faite par frédéric un atelier peinture
collage d'animaux cris en objets de
récupération pour les plus jeunes et
surtout un déjeuner sur ma faim oui
surtout pour les amateurs de violence
bien sûr alors le menu donne l'eau à la
bouche
un barbecue sur le thème du boeuf à colt
est d'arriver d'art charcuterie une
pièce devant de viande pardon et surtout
si vous reste de la place une charlotte
fait maison
un petit pour petite précision les
animations sont gratuites par contre
pour le repas il ya une participation
entre 17 et 25 euros qui est demandé et
vous pourrez aussi découvrir les
produits les acheter en détail surtout
échanger avec martin et frédéric sur
leur travail
non mais c'est très très important on a
beaucoup de questions lors de cette
journée de top 7 journées de portes
ouvertes sur notre métier comment quand
elle est de nos difficultés et puis ça
m'est été rude difficile financièrement
c'est par amitié très rémunérateur mais
bon voilà c'est un métier de passion
plein vent toujours et comme vous le
disiez un peu plus tôt camille d'autres
fermes participent à cette fête la ferme
de waro à son chant qui propose là aussi
des balades de poney et à dos d'âne et
une visite du verger de pommiers et
pourquoi pas des déguster le pardon ce
jus de pomme du côté de senlis et la
ferme de fans sur sa boutique de 9h à
18h leurs produits des escargots des
terrines de gibier
des oeufs et des confitures et pour
terminer on va à la bergerie nationale
de rambouillet qui participent à cette
fête alors un petit déjeuner bio est
organisée de 9 heures à midi dans la
cour royale et vous pourrez aussi
déguster la mozzarella à la ferme
pédagogique
il y aura aussi une exposition sur le
travail de litchi voilà une journée au
coeur de la ferme à la rencontre des
producteurs locaux et de leurs animaux
on le rappelle c'est dimanche 4 juin 4
juin dans les fermes de la vallée de
chevreuse merci beaucoup mais anip
auquel vous avoir présenté les
différentes animations c'est la fin de
ce set 8 loisirs je vous retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
et je vous souhaite un excellent week
end
[Musique]